we did a show in Detroit and we did a
place called buddy's met the whole
family played bocce ball with them they
were Italian a guy worked in a factory
and his wife would cook and she says get
something so I could make pizza and he
brought these pans it they used to keep
nuts and bolts wound up making a
delicious pizza it was just very robust
that's what I remember about it the most
when I bit it it bit me back
here we are round two I'm Sal I'm friend
we're at lions and tigers and squares in
New York City corner of 23rd and 8th
Avenue selling detroit pizza or new york
city you know it's really cool about
Detroit style pizzas we never got to put
cheddar cheese on a pizza
usually pizza you just think what's it
oh but melted burnt cheddar cheese is
delicious nothing like what's it Oh has
a different flavor profile entire
totally different and the way they do it
is super cool I mean a lot of fat is
going into the dough and it's flavoring
the dough and it's texturising the day
and then we're putting hot sauce when it
comes out we quality Troy pizza with a
New York accent
[Music]
so we don't want to give you all our
secrets but what we do is the dough's
are rolled by hand they're putting
proofing boxes and then they bring it up
to us and we top it off and cook it
right in the oven so the cheddar were
actually sourcing it from Wisconsin
we're working with a packer directly and
he made us our own boy not super sharp
but we just wanted a good quality Chetta
they get put into the oven 500 degrees
we cooked the pizza for about 10 minutes
in that oven it has a stone hearth so
you get bottom heat and it cooks it from
the bottom to the top we're set up here
to do volume those ovens do a lot of
body you got that thin metal pan which
is super conducive to the heat so you
have that souffle effect and then we're
putting hot sauce when it comes out a
lot of garlic a lot of parsley a lot of
crushed red pepper spicy salty delicious
mom has a recipe on it's actually
Obama's cosmic from Detroit's recipe
that's right anyway it just it really
works well because you don't cover the
whole surface with the sauce so you can
see the cheese you can see the sauce we
garnish it with a little bit of fresh
parsley I put a little sprinkle of
pecorino at the end I'm a New Yorker and
I can't not do it I put it on my cereal
in the morning Detroit does a lot of
topping this plane is probably the most
popular but I would say pepperoni after
that we use the best pepperoni there
and cut baby for mouth nothing but the
best Hormel makes us our own blend
I got our own pigs the casing is very
you know good for cup and curl we do
sausage onion butter parsley a little
bit of maple syrup when it comes out
kind of tastes like a McDonald's
breakfast delicious different do a nice
mushroom pie
I put the big giant mushrooms we put
them on Raw a lot of possibly a lot of
garlic white wine it's all good
all right so mustard pizzas I'm not
really a Detroit thing but a delicious
then my buddy from Paris he says in
France they all make pizza with Dijon
mustard and Brie a so we do it with
brown spicy mustard and cheddar there's
also a guy in Trenton New Jersey is
famous for a mustard part called pop
this tomato pies it's delicious no any
differences he puts tomato sauce so
pizzas come a long way guys all right
I'm gonna do it with a little brisket no
little sauerkraut
just the right amount to make it
delicious give you a little crunch a
little sour I cover it with cheddar
cheese and that are gonna go into the
oven about 12 minutes you're gonna beat
mustard pizza knobs you got room in that
oven
Detroit is a great city I mean you got
to remember something Domino's is from
Detroit right jex is from Detroit
Little Caesars is from Detroit you know
Detroit's of pizza city I mean come on
people forget that right I mean Detroit
has got a lot of great pizza even though
New Yorkers could be a little
territorial about pizza pizza is always
constantly evolving here and a lot of
people they're curious to know what a
Detroit pie is so we put a five dollar
pizza out there just to let the people
try it
we call it slices by the pot guy comes
in goes let me get a slice sure we sell
fight a whole squid it's five bucks cut
it in four corners sold out the door I
mean it was a combination of loving the
way that it tastes loving the way that
it looked and loving the way that it
came about coming get away inside hurry
up
[Music]
you
[Music]
you